all right guys we're gonna try not to
get kicked out of here what is going on
there citizens of the reject Nation we
just got done literally like 10 minutes
ago watching Spider-Man across the
spider-verse you guys could flip that
like button that'd be very much
appreciated we're gonna have to keep
this really quick but first you gotta
work from our sponsor greetings trekkies
and Trek curious prepare for warp speed
because we're gonna Venture into the
Star Trek universe thanks to our
sponsors Star Trek Fleet command this
free to play open world MMO lets you
take command of your very own star base
on the edge of the final frontier beam
up and construct fleets of your favorite
starships and recruits iconic officers
to your crew as you chart a course
toward your expanding territory Vanquish
Rivals nine resources and uncover the
secrets of strange new worlds prepare to
embark on a Voyage to the mysterious
Delta quadrant Uncharted space is filled
with Unthinkable dangers that will put
your fleet's abilities to the ultimate
Kobayashi Maru test so round up your
crew and customize your Fleet because
there's no triple at all and taking
control of your own Starships so engage
with a strange new world to seek out new
life and civilizations and boldly go
dominate the Galaxy get ready to make it
so with Star Trek Fleet command's new
Voyager Arc with over 20 fresh missions
game changing features and the return of
some beloved characters truly an
experience to set your tricoders
worrying if you're ready to join the
millions of players already warping
through the Galaxy assembling their
fleets and taking part in spaceship
battles Hit our link below or scan the
QR code on your screen to download Star
Trek Fleet command today it's a strap in
Starfleet Cadets and set your phasers
to fun
all right so real quick the plot of this
movie trying to keep it to what the
trailers have shown us is to not spoil
it miles he reunites with Gwen and gets
flung into the Multiverse he meets a
whole Squad of spider people who are
basically the Guardians of the
Multiverse these Heroes they start
bumping heads on how to deal with this
new threat they're facing which is a
fantastic debate by the way I'm probably
going to talk a lot more on that later
on in this video that creates a massive
conflict between miles and the other
spiders so with this whole journey
they're upping their animation style and
action sequences but really at its core
it's a story about acceptance and Miles
having to redefine his whole idea of
what it means to be a hero he's got to
dig deep and figure out how to save the
people he loves most some serious
soul-searching right here as bigger
as this film is as higher Stakes as this
movie is it's also a much more personal
more intimate film about Miles Morales
and especially about Gwen Stacy arguably
this is just equally her movie as well
in fact the prologue of this film
without giving anything away is very
much about her spot is as teased in the
trailer is the villain as funny as he is
in this movie he also becomes something
that you can see is wow that is one of
the most threatening villains you have
to deal with John what did you think
about it I'm still piecing my brain
together which is a good thing this was
spectacular in every sense of the word
but yeah coming out of the first movie
which is such a lovely you know
imaginative sprawling experience that
also has this great Coming of Age story
inside I thought they just managed to
build on top of that and to keep the
character heft the actual emotional
story super engaged while giving you
swaths of references and new universes
and new visual Styles and languages Like
It Is A Feast for the eyes and ears and
everything in between it's overwhelming
but in a way that is really satisfying
and fun and begs you to come back time
and again I would imagine I mean it's
overwhelming in the same way how the
first time you watched into the
spider-verse might have felt
overwhelming at first as well there were
things about it where I'm like okay is
the pacing off a tadpe here is this too
much that's being thrown at my face
right now instantly follow the thought
of I bet on a re-watch it would not feel
this way whatsoever because into the
spider-verse out of the Spider-Man films
it is my favorite of the Spider-Man
movies I want to watch it again before I
say a statement like this I think I like
this one more than the first one gotta
keep in mind this is also a part one of
a you know of a two-parter here for the
sequels does it end on a cliffhanger yes
it ends on a cliffhanger and man I
didn't want it to end though I
definitely didn't want it I was like oh
man you can feel when it's about time
you're like oh crap I forgot there's
supposed to be a part three to conclude
this story he's making a five hour movie
go it's a complete film still for a part
two the it's been a while since I've
seen a movie that really ends on such a
cliffhanger where the story of this will
not entirely be complete until you watch
the next one yet it's still like
remember how the Lord of the Rings
movies felt that way it has that effect
kind of like an Empire Strikes Back or
two towers the reason why it feels
complete is because they have such a
personal tale here of what Gwen Stacy
has to go through and that's where so
much of the personal journey and what
makes this specific installment feel
that much more complete without giving
it away you know same for miles but he's
got so much more of his character to
tell bigger Stakes of the film as it is
and is more bombastic and a crazy
cacophony of events that are taking
place here it still had so many more
scenes as compared to the first one that
felt much slower more are intimate
they're just like scenes like dialogue
character scenes that were not about
crazy Vivid animation just character
scenes with so many of the characters
that had so much dramatic heft heart and
tension at times especially with the
parents there's some truly Exquisite
scenes with the parents that propelled
this movie forward and in fact so much
of this coming of age story is also
about parenting they're spliced
throughout this whole movie that also
made this film feel that much more I
don't want to just say the word
harrowing because I feel like I abused
that word sometimes but it does it makes
it feel that much more harrowing it is a
bit of a harrowing journey I mean the
fate of the Multiverse hangs on the
balance for also what's personally at
stake here for these characters it's so
much darker than the first one it's a
much it's darker than a lot of the other
Spider-Man movies we've seen you know
what it does it really hones in on the
hardships and themes that we know of
Spider-Man characters and make such a
great meta commentary on it but doesn't
get lost in the meta commentary on it it
gets you invested in the turbulent
trials of what one has to endure on such
a grand yet small scale that's so
impressive how they do it yeah and it's
also again super Universal and intimate
because even though these are being
applied to these science fiction Stakes
so much of what is happening is building
off of again the coming of age story
that came before and just the
confronting of life as you come of age
as you become an adult as you become
fully formed there are going to be
trials and tribulations that you cannot
avoid and sometimes life is going to
throw you a bad hand or some kind of
thing that you cannot negotiate or just
go back and fix and that is at the
center of what's going on here so
there's like a harsh lesson being
learned and I think it's something too
that's interesting to split into two
parts because it's something that we all
bargain with to one degree or another it
just happens to be applied to these you
know comic book style stakes and
Aesthetics and the art style too I mean
as beautiful and Grand as it was the
first time around I thought they made
that even more expressive here so that
the emotionality of the scene work and
even those scenes that are just
breathing and aren't so kinetic have the
bolstering of the art that feels very
alive and again like even though this is
probably all made on a computer it feels
like somebody took the time to draw it
and really put that care into everything
and the array of other characters too
and and the little glimpses into their
versions of the trials and tribulations
of a Spider-Man Spider Woman whatever
you know it all comes back to something
relatable and Universal even though yeah
it's so high concept yeah there's a lot
of these great dream like abstract
Expressions that they'll do that are
just about the hardships and the terror
that's going on within like Miles
Morales especially in this movie
sequences where it's like this is just
something that's taking place within his
mind it has a bit of that cerebral
effect of the horrors of the things you
gotta face within that are also
manifesting itself externally it's it's
so much deeper than the first one and
but it's still really funny it's a
really funny movie at the same time I
mean some characters that have been
teased within the trailers you know like
spider Punk uh he's hilarious rock star
character Anarchist like this 60s 70s
type of rock and roller anti-capitalism
sjw yeah yeah just the Locust guy look
out yeah but he's still so freaking
awesome yeah so awesome commentary he
makes are made a lot of times for jokes
it's never like making a serious
messenger point with him implementing
him here with his crazy Expressions
again with his animation style are
awesome one character I was surprised by
as well I don't know how to pronounce
his name the Spider-Man India character
he was hilarious what a wonderful
addition to this whole universe and a
beautiful world of Mumbai whatever the
combination of Mumbai Brooklyn is yeah
and then of course you got Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 299 what I loved about it is
in the trailers when you watch it you're
like okay is he gonna be a villain he
does have this
I don't want to give it away because
it's so much more gray and that's one of
the coolest Parts about it is the film
definitely has like an a threatening
quality about him yet I wouldn't
categorize him as a villain there's such
a debate at its core that was like kind
of given away uh there's so much more to
it there's so much more meat around it
than what's in the trailers there is a
debate surrounding an inner conflict
that happens between him and uh miles
that involves you know what it really
means to be a Spider-Man and certain
sacrifices one has to make and it is a
fantastic debate that this movie's
having because even I'm there and I'm
rooting for miles at the same time I'm
in my the audience seat going is Miles
making the right choice
yeah we would all be in your shoes but
also look at the big picture I get that
Miguel's a terrible communicator but I
guess he's just such an aggressive
at the same time you're like but
what if Miguel is the one who is right
about this right what if he's the only
one who's willing to go through with
what's right yeah yeah it does a great
job at painting that there's not as much
ben Reilly as I think some people might
want in here kind of like soften the
blow a little bit there Jessica Drew was
another very fun welcome addition who
brings a lot of energy and commands the
screen whenever she's there the movie's
more suspenseful than the last one it's
more intense it's more complex and that
complexity is such a compliment to it
because it easily could have been over
convoluted yet it doesn't go past that
line I feel like this movie is
phenomenal I think it's inspiring one of
the best animated movies I've ever seen
yeah I mean is it leave you off on a
note that is as fun or hopeful like the
first movie while crazy is still simple
compared to what this is yeah but this
one absolutely leaves you wanting more
right now and it leaves off in a place
where you go ah but then you immediately
feel that swell of having been through a
cathartic and Grand experience and yeah
it leaves you with tons to appreciate
and anticipate all at the same time
again on my first few women there were
parts and specifically like the first 30
to 40 minutes because it could be such
like a kinetic ride and then we got a
really serious scene here and it's
slowing me down and I was like I don't
know if it's just because I'm coming off
the high of that kinetic scene that
sometimes I was like having a bit of a
difficult time I wouldn't even say
difficult it was going to calibrate your
brain you do got to calibrate your mind
and hard at times to go okay now we're
slowing down yeah yeah absolutely but I
wouldn't have it any other way a perfect
way to do a part two because it takes
the events of what happened in the first
one and this is the residual
consequences carrying over into here but
still telling a different story but
carrying on the same story is the next
chapter of a life it's a strong ass film
man you're flawless I can't believe it
was like 40 minutes and I'm like I can't
believe they just did it again like they
did it again and better like yeah it's
rarely occasion that I come into one of
these without like worries that they're
gonna clear the bar but they just
effortlessly you know swept me off on a
journey with this and yeah this might be
one of the greatest sequels to one of
the greatest comic book movies a hundred
thousand percent on Rotten Tomatoes
I see you guys did you see this movie
what are you most looking forward to if
you haven't seen it leave your thoughts
down below what do you hope to see in
part three which they I don't know if
they've revealed the title already but
they reveal the title of the third one
at the end of this movie if you didn't
know the title already so yeah uh anyway
the title's like ah great title exactly
yeah leave your thoughts down below
thank you so much for being here we will
talk with you all soon thanks again guys